The cicada situation is out of control
Oh good morning Hank, it's Tuesday, so when we last visited the garden
it was mostly dirt
but now there are zucchini and sunflowers and these weird dragon tongue beans.
We've got eggplants and oregano
and most of all we have tomatoes
We've got  black cherry tomatoes, we've got red cherry tomatoes, we've got these weird guys
and we've also got a metric crap ton of golden currants
which are tiny little tomatoes not much larger than a pea.
Why did I get so many tomato plants that make tiny tomatoes?
Because I wanna eat 211 tomatoes in a single sitting.
One, two...
Five... This is gonna take a while
I have picked the tomatoes. It took thirty four minutes and I am drenched in sweat.
Let's go inside
Actually you know what, before we go, picking all of these tomatoes has made me wanna eat a tomato
So I'm going to, hold on
Mmm, delicious
I'm gonna have another one
Mmm. New video title, "How to Eat 213 Tomatoes in a Single Sitting"
Okay so the first thing you're gonna want to do is lay out your bountiful harvest
and then consider all of the time, energy and sweat that went into the creation of this 900 calories of food.
Then, give thanks to actual farm workers
And then count out exactly 211 tomatoes because people on the internet are sticklers about that stuff
So today we're going to make panzanella
which is essentially tomatoes with croutons.
To make the croutons you wanna preheat the oven to 350 degrees,
being careful not to look at your ghoulish reflection
Then take a pan, tear up some good bread, put it in four-ish cloves of minced garlic, some olive oil
and then I think the technical term is you just
sort of 'hoosh' it.
And then once it's adequately 'hooshed' put it in the oven and cook it for, I don't know, like 15 minutes
Then you're gonna want to chop up all of your non-golden currant tomatoes
and
boom
It was at this point that I realised that even 211 small tomatoes
is still a lot of tomatoes
I googled "can eating too many tomatoes kill you?"
and it turns out, probably not, but it can turn your skin orange
Incidentally, you may not think you like tomatoes.
I thought I hated them until my late twenties
but it turned out I had just never had a good one.
Tomatoes are one of the very few foods where the good version
is essentially like a different thing than the bad version
Another example would be the difference between actual Lucky Charms and knock off Lucky Charms
So lets go back to the recipe
So you wanna put all your tomatoes in a large bowl, add some balsamic vinegar
less olive oil than I just used, some salt and pepper
and then, 'hoosh'.
The secret to panzanella is the crunch of the croutons combined with the juicyness of the tomatoes
So it doesn't keep well once mixed.
If you want leftovers, you need to keep them separate and then add them together as you go.
So once your croutons are toasty, mix a handful with a handful of tomatoes
put some sliced basil on the top and you've got yourself an excellent meal.
I ate around a hundred tomatoes at lunch
and then Sarah and I split the remaining tomatoes at dinner
Three great meals and my skin did not even turn orange
Now I just gotta figure out what to do with those zucchini
Hank, I'll see you on Friday.